hello and welcome to this episode of not
too deep I'm grace Helbig this episode
is very exciting we have Mia Donato here
with us and she's a gymnast turned
tick-tock ER turned adorable child that
owns a ton of boxers dogs not the
athletes and I really picked her brain
about tick tock and I came away with
knowing no more than I knew before this
episode
either way we had a real wonderful time
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
Mia Donato deep it's time to turn that
great idea you have into a reality and
you can do that with Squarespace they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project with you're showcasing
your work or selling products of any
kind they have beautiful templates and
the ability to customize just about
anything so you can easily make a
beautiful website yourself and if you do
get stuck they have 24/7 award-winning
customer support that is there to help
so head to squarespace.com slash Grace
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use the offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain I just got this new
like job and I was like trying to manage
with like that like a bunch of emails I
decide a bunch of things and it was
getting confusing so forget all that no
that's something else okay am I allowed
to talk about yes oh wait how we started
yep oh my
[Laughter]
oh my gosh okay can we dive in and talk
about trophies yeah trophies I'm so
excited yeah tell us about this what's
going on it's like it's a pilot it's
about like cheerleading and like all the
stuff that cheerleaders like go through
and it's not it's not like the typical
it just like school cheerleader like
that competitive competitive cheerleader
yeah and it's gonna be I'm not sure if
it's gonna be she wants it to be the
writer wants it to be a drama okay but
the people she pitched it to want it to
be like a dramedy they wanted to be more
comedy gotcha
like I think she really wants it to be
more drama but I'm excited we are
filming the pilot at the end of the
month coming we start she's pitching it
to like Hulu net I don't know actually
I'm not I don't know if I'm going to say
all of it they're all listening now it's
not good so okay let's back up for a
second because you come from a
competitive gymnastics background yes
which I also did for a little bit I got
to level five year level ten I respect
to the nth degree at what you do how
when did that start and stop for you
like when did you start doing gymnastics
and when did it and Anu transitioned
into like social media okay so it
started so I was always doing gymnastics
when I was little I did like gymnastics
I did dance yeah I did
same I did dancing gymnastics and my
dance teacher told my mom she should
only do gymnastics she very elegantly
told my mom that I have no rhythm and
that maybe I should just tumble yeah
well that's funny but you're probably a
great gymnast I'm great at throwing my
body into situations I started off in
gymnastics dance as I said and I had to
pick the cut because the gymnastics team
the gymnastics I was doing it at it was
just like a little mom-and-pop like gym
okay the guy was telling me she's really
good she should go and this was still
when I was really young
yeah she should go to like a competitive
gym and she should compete and then the
dance studio I was at also wanted me to
compete
so I like didn't have time today so my
mom is like you got a pick which one you
want to do and I'm like gymnastics I
love to gymnastic yeah I like to doing
okay I liked doing dance but I didn't
like the teachers telling me what to do
I'm like I just have to turn on the
music and I just want to dance like why
do they have to tell me what to do why
do I need choreography wouldn't gonna
freestyle the whole time no and I hated
going across the floor and doing like
cakes like you could go across the floor
and like do flips and stuff now you feel
very strong and powerful and thought of
like shaking your ass like that sorry to
curse in front of you no no no you're
totally fine my my family it's like
you're from Maryland I get a East Coast
girl I'm computer Z yeah so it's all in
the family
yeah okay so you decided at a young age
that you were gonna pursue gymnastics
yeah so at this point I was really young
you know I honestly I'm so bad at like
ageism I was like I'm six okay so the
gymnastics out that he was like you
should go somewhere else and she should
try to get or not try to she should be
competing because she's really well
right good and so then I went to we
didn't know what we were doing we're
sure so we went to another really bad
gym they competed but they were like at
the lowest of the low we didn't know it
was close to it but also I don't think
people understand that with gymnastics
and with gyms like it's really about
like the coaches you have it's about the
community that's there and that there
are good gyms and badges so we didn't
know like we eventually once I was doing
it for years and years we knew like
that's also an expensive sport so like
your parents are paying money for you to
go compete and be part of this program
and you find out that it's not that
great like yeah yeah so that's what
happened so I was at a gym I went there
and then we went to another gym it was
like across the street from it it was it
was better but it like still wasn't a
great gym yeah like at all right then
after that gym yeah there's a lot of
gyms cuz like we didn't know what we're
doing at first course and so for level
four five and six
that hills gymnastics okay and they've
had it like a bunch of people go to the
Olympics and they were like the best the
best gym in the state okay and it was
really I I really liked it it was like
really hard at first because it was
super strict yeah like it I made a lot
of great friends there when I was
younger but it was it was a little far
away but no it actually wasn't as far it
was like 45 minutes okay that's not that
bad compared to what I ended up going to
but so then you go there and then you go
to this other gym yes and then a lot of
stuff was happening I was I go through
like a lot I was going through a lot of
like um like worries and stuff like I've
OCD and anxiety and a lot of stuff and
gymnastics is the most insane sport for
anyone that is slightly like yeah
anxious in any way yes definitely it is
so intense when I tell people like oh
yeah I competed quote-unquote in
gymnastics in like seventh and eighth
grade I spent four hours at a gym every
single night they're like yeah what yes
it's insane yeah so when I was at that
gym it was four hours every night yeah
and so and my worries I would like worry
a lot like later in the day as well and
yeah it was just like a really anxious
kid like oh you're supposed to like have
perfection they're like presenting
yourself in such a way and so they teach
you like everything has to be perfect
yeah some things happened at that gym
and then it didn't end up working out
for me so then I went to another gym and
that's I know it sounds like I'm like a
gym hopper but this isn't like the span
of like probably 14 years okay so it's
not like I'm going like this didn't know
like years at gyms we were just figuring
out what's the best place for me yeah
and so then I went to this gym called
like first class and that's like there
was like a bunch of like social media
people there like I didn't know oh so
this was your first introduction to
social media in the gym space yeah it
was it was like so there was like this
thieves like girls they did like like a
bunch of um did like YouTube channels
and stuff and there was like a gym
school like and then we had like a
YouTube channel like all together
that the coach trainer we did like
challenges and it was like oh that's
fine it was really fun and I had no idea
about like any of this stuff so that was
your introduction to like YouTube to
that whole world gymnastics so like yeah
that's a genre that I'm not familiar
with online yeah it was crazy cause like
at first I recognized the one girl from
there and I was like where have I seen
Oh cuz like she did gymnastics too and I
I knew like all the gymnastics youtubers
sure that cuz I did gymnastics and I
thought it was cool I'm like hey and I
saw like myself in the background of one
of their videos so it was really cool to
like so that was your introduction so
there did you start doing stuff on your
own after that yeah so this is what
happened so like I was just like in a
lot of my friends say they were like
really popular on social media and I was
just they were like my good friends yeah
and I was just I hung out with them and
I was in their videos and then people
started to like find my Instagram and
then I was like oh my gosh that's weird
people are starting to find their kids
like I I was like I don't get it any of
it's crazy like so you had this like
trickle-down of people following other
people and then finding you and you're
like what am I supposed to do with this
yeah and then so I was just and I've
always wanted to make videos
I'm always my friend and I my best
friend and I when we were younger we
made YouTube videos you never posted
them because our parents were like you
can't post him online so I really we
just made him for our self and we showed
like our family members our grandparents
like hey guys our channel was called
pineapple pillows perfect we just
thought it sounded cool shoutout to
Kelly she's a huge fan of the podcast
she's listening right now oh my gosh no
way so you never made this channel no we
never made that we did it we did like a
bunch of video stars we did like gym
like you know like the music video
traditional lip synced we took it
seriously we would like invite like it
was like a whole production is how I
started yeah college roommate and I
start
making lip sync videos too like Lil Mama
and Avril Lavigne and so that's I can't
judge you in any negative way because
I've been there done that legitimately
we probably honestly like this is not an
exaggeration we've been friends since we
were like seven and we've probably made
like over like a thousand videos like
like we've made a bunch of lip synching
ones now there's like videofxlive which
is the same as video star but like you
can talk and it's not like so okay
that's how I started
I've always liked making videos but then
once I came here and all these people
are on YouTube and stuff and my parents
was getting familiar with it yeah like
man you can't like have a public social
media like it's dangerous there's people
out there that are like weirdos of
course and like they were learning stuff
because like all my friends were doing
and I'm like mom they're do their
accounts are public can I just make my
account public cause I want to post
these videos that I make because I'm not
just wasting my time and making him for
myself and and we just met your mom
before we started recording and she
seems rad Oh oh my gosh my parents are
the best like it's there literally it
literally is so great like they're so
like chillax they're not like the likes
to not like so many of my friends feel
like there's like a good amount of
parents that I know I'm like oh my gosh
I do not know what I would do if that
was my mom I'm like drippers and so like
she's so chill we're so like we get in
fights
of course like my mom's really sensitive
and I like I can't wait for her to come
I've learned a lot about you know wait
so she so she's the one that gave you
permission for everything to go find my
dad her my dad do everything like it's
always like ask your mom ask your dad
they make it together it's my and if one
parents leaning towards know then the
other ones good but like ya know the
other ones lean toward yes it's like
yeah okay yeah okay so then you go you
start making videos and then how long
ago is this so you start making videos
like making videos for fun since like
7:00 okay but how long ago that it's
actually on the internet people can
watch this
oh my goodness three years three years
ago okay yeah easy and now
tick-tock this is what I want to get
into oh my gosh
what is tick tock tock oh my gosh how do
you thanks and I'm asking this very
genuinely I'm not really no no I
literally do not I don't have it
downloaded on my phone huh I don't know
what it is yeah how would you explain -
okay so it started out it started out as
musically and that's also how I got a
big start on my social media
I didn't start getting popular on
YouTube or Instagram
I got popular from musically okay and my
friends I we just did like little lip
synching video the read took those so
seriously - and they're so cringe I've
watched musically videos and it it's
very impressive to me I can't do it like
the way that it's like stop-motion
almost it looks not oh my gosh it's so
you start doing that and yeah and then
how you getting like I got like two
million followers on that and I was
getting like 200,000 likes per video
like and I was just lip-syncing it's not
even like I was making constant you're
like I've been working in a gym for
years and the one thing that requires no
physical energy and motion you literally
we put a lot of effort into it to make
sure it was good but like it was more
about like oh my face looks weird on
this one so it's like yeah yeah at the
point I took it seriously but looking
back I'm like oh my gosh of course it's
a tick tock
it changed company bought it right at
first we were like what the heck
musically change it basically like duh
was like dying like Noah Graham did it
buddy fine yeah yeah like fine but then
they like rebranded it and now it's like
more popular than ever and it's like
Tech Talk is we're different than
musically and I like it way better and
it's so funny you can the thing about
take talk you can get trapped in it like
like going through the for you page it's
a day
some of them are so funny and then like
you're like oh my gosh that's hilarious
and then he keeps going and then you're
there for hours and it feels like 10
minutes and you're like so it's like
Instagram Explorer page yes but on tick
tock yes I think it's more addicting I
want
oh and my mom was telling someone that I
just met this guy he doesn't do social
media or anything oh yeah she was I I
kind on the roof for a tick-tock my mom
wasn't real happy about that
she told this guy that I just met about
my he didn't do social media she was
like yeah she was filming a tick-tock
tick-tock it's yeah I feel like anyone
that I see in Los Angeles that's acting
a little bit out of the ordinary I will
assume is making a tick-tock oh my gosh
I just saw like my friend he was he was
like screaming like a song in the middle
of Hollywood Boulevard for a tick-tock
I'm like I'm not I could about right I'm
bad at filming in public that's why I
can't vlog I want one I don't like it
cause like when I'm in the middle of
something like it just feels awkward so
guys like so awkward
I give credit to people that could just
pull out their camera and make it
totally natural like right I and I don't
wanna be that person like no I have
shame boom yeah I have shame I get
embarrassed and I don't want to do that
for myself and the people that I am
friends but they can unabashedly just
pull out a camera and go this is exactly
what's happening right now you know when
I was vlogging you know what I would do
I'm it's like my vlogs were like not
traditional books like I've videoed it
and then a like half of the video was
like a little segment called me editing
it's like I'm explaining what's
happening director's cut of your own
vlog in real time as you're laughing
like ok so right now I'm about to go to
this place and I'm like so I just met up
because I don't wanna be like so guys
I'm with this because it's awkward I'm
like I was I just video in it and one
time I was in the middle I was like
going something cool and I just videoed
a little clip of me just like but ya
know I get really embarrassed to like
video stuff but
that must be so where do you I mean
there must be like it's really fun to
record yourself in and do all of that
but also to live a life without
recording it like do you ever feel like
that's why I don't like vlogging yeah
it's kids like and put your phone down
actually experience at the moment the
time yeah don't the only reason I really
wouldn't feel that I would love falling
it's because it's cool to go back and
watch them yeah from like a year ago
when I first started like doing I don't
flog anymore but I did like a series
where I went I was coming to LA for
three months and I was vlogging and it's
fun to go back and watch them it's like
I remember that that's so cool yeah but
like during it it's just like it's it's
like oh this videos aren't like fun to
make for me like I like doing like
challenges and like fun stuff and like
I've been I've been honestly like
slacking off on like YouTube and
Instagram and girls saying it's good
like I've been really focusing on like
the acting and like a bunch of stuff is
happening but like okay we're gonna get
we're gonna take a quick break but I
want to talk about your acting I want to
talk about your auditioning I want to
talk about how you got blood all over
your face that you couldn't wash off a
few weeks ago talking about DIY okay
we're gonna take a quick break when we
get back we have more with Mia on not
too deep we'll be right back it's the
time of the episode in which I tell you
all about our dear friends over at
Squarespace because they're supporting
us today Squarespace makes it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
do you want to start a new business do
you want to showcase some of your work
do you want to publish content sell
products or more Squarespace is the tool
for you they have beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks so you can easily make
a beautiful website all by yourself
Squarespace is powerful ecommerce
functionality lets you sell anything
online and they have analytics that help
you grow your site in real time and
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and if you need help get it with
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support Squarespace empowers
millions of people from designers to
lawyers artists to gamers even
restaurants and gyms to turn great ideas
into something real go to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that squarespace.com slash grace
offer code grace too deep today we have
support from a brewery and not in the
way that you might think and also I know
I cannot say the word brewery they'll
get ready to hear me try and say a bunch
in the next two minutes are you ever in
the mood for a great tasting beer but
not the buzz that comes with it then
enter Brooklyn breweries special effects
a delicious flavorful brand new brew
that happens to be non-alcoholic with
special effects Brooklyn Brewery is
changing the stigma around non-alcoholic
beer it's not just for folks who don't
drink alcohol special effects is brewed
for people who want something tasty and
fresh but aren't looking for alcohol at
that moment it's here to help you do
more with your days and nights who's to
say that you can't work a few special
effects into a night of cocktails to
keep it going longer or perhaps you're
thinking of cutting back overall you got
options
Brooklyn's special effects is a poppy
lager style brew that comes in at under
0.5 percent ABV alcohol by volume I
believe don't hold me to that that's
about as much alcohol as you'll find in
a ripe banana is that what sorry I'm
stunned by this ad copy reach and I'm
intrigued at the same time they sent me
some of the special effects and I gotta
say guys it tastes great tastes like a
beer if you're a beer drinking kind of
person but you want to wake up without a
hangover but still get that you know
delicious beer flavor then this is for
you
special effects is ready for any where
you're going anything you're doing and
anyone you choose to do it with so go to
Brooklyn Brewery dot-com slash special
effects for more info and to see where
you can pick up a six-pack or tune near
you do more with Brooklyn Brewery
special effects
okay so you start getting into social
media you start doing tick-tock you're
getting in this world at the same time
are you acting
I'm act yes the same oh oh okay so when
I first started get to get into all of
that stuff I wait I've wanted to act
since I was like ever since I was doing
like the dance the gymnastics yeah but
it cuz it's a natural progression I feel
like when you're doing gymnastics you're
putting on a show
you're literally putting on a show so
I've always wanted to act but like also
I'm from Maryland like mhm there's
nowhere you can really act besides like
a school play or yeah so I I kind of
before the social media stuff I kind of
just like took a long look in the mirror
and just like you're probably never
gonna become an actor you're not gonna
go to LA and act there's so many actors
and like you're just like another random
person sure doesn't so and it just
wasn't I deal and I was I was on the
road to get like a scholarship for
college to mastics that's what I was
planning on doing right and I don't know
that's just what I was thinking I was
the next step for seven like gymnastics
gymnastics like when I met someone I'd
be like hi I'm a I'm a gymnast like
that's I felt like I was a gymnast that
was your identity yeah yeah when I
decided to stop gymnastics cuz a lot of
things happened I was at level 10 it's
the highest level it's hard to find good
coaches right and if I started off at a
really good gym like I got better over
the years like I wasn't in level 9 I was
really good and then like my first year
level 10 like the coaching stuff
happened and like I wasn't as good 10 I
was I wasn't like but at that point you
do decide like what's the end game are
you gonna go to the Olympics what are
you gonna do that's how do you make a
drop off of stopping I was starting to
not like gymnastics for the past couple
of years but I felt like I was stuck
yeah because I'm like you know what
that's what you put your most time and
energy into like I've spent every waking
like I did school at the gym yeah in the
home school program with like the social
media stuff it was that gym I went to we
were there for your whole life and I was
there over like eight hours a day wait
for entire time have an eight eight and
a half hours a day I was there yes no
and I lived like an hour
a Jedi did school there and everything
but like I had my best friend's err it's
like a boarding school no no way like
you go off for an hour and you are with
your friends and you're doing school and
this is the only life that you know yeah
and so anything outside of Maryland
anything outside of that like yeah Jim
I'm sure it was like how could I
possibly do any of that and so yeah when
I was in gymnastics and I was doing the
social media stuff I was like I really
want to get into acting but like I can't
cuz of gymnastics it yeah but stuff
happened like I stopped gymnastics and
then I'm like maybe I can finally do it
now and I didn't really know I didn't
really know what I was like getting into
at first for some reason I thought I
could do acting and stuff but like still
like be at home the whole time I kind of
just jumped like this is what happened
my parents like okay we're gonna I got a
manager like we're gonna try this for
three months for pilot season and then
we're just gonna go back home and see if
we want to do it again next year I
thought it was just like you come out
here for the three mono huh and then
next year you come out for another three
months no no no I know it's it's like
there's not a specific season because
there's Netflix Hulu and they all film
at random times and it's like yeah I am
filming like a bunch of random stuff and
then it's like once I go home I'm like
I'm home from what you said home and
said to Maryland accent right now you
just said home like like oh really see I
don't even know I had Marilyn accent my
dialect coach was helping me with a big
audition I had and he was like you say
it like how you were saying I don't like
what do you mean I'm like I don't think
I'm pronouncing it the way ya spelled
yeah like you say it yeah that sounds
the same and then at home listen I do
yeah yeah I know I dated a guy from
Maryland for a long time and yeah the
same thing
oh really yeah go oh yeah hum everyone
says hun down there it's very sweet okay
so then you get into acting yeah you
come out here and do you live out here
now so we've rented a house for a year
okay yeah so it's like we can just like
kiss so this is what happened we've
rented a place in Glendale it was a
really nice apartment it's really
expensive because we were only doing it
for three months and then it was like
that tick-tock money okay so you're out
here and you're it's you and your mom
and you're sharing it right with like a
friend and there yeah so first it's so
first we're here for three months
uh-huh after the three months I I did
some I got some stuff a couple things
like short films I'm like that and I was
like okay I'm ready to go back home but
three months is up let's go yeah I was
on the plane and I decided to get Wi-Fi
on the plane something like you know
what why not treat yourself all the time
six hour flight I know I can't not be
connected yeah I know I was looking
through my emails I'm like let's be
productive and going through my emails
and I'm like wait I got a oh so I got a
project but crown Lake and they're like
yeah we want you tomorrow and I was on
the plane so we had to land I went back
to see my dogs which was great I missed
them but then like I wasn't even there
for like 12 hours and you immediately
had to come right back yeah and then we
had and we already got rid of all we
sent our clothes all the way back home
we didn't have a place to stay so we had
to stay in this like really like it was
like a bad spot and like Hollywood
Airbnb it was like not a good area and
like it was like a studio apartment so
if we didn't have any like walls like my
mom and I I felt bad for my mom and she
was just like buy or sell boundaries she
was just like by herself the whole times
I was working and she was like getting
lonely I'm always working it's like if
I'm not working on acting that I'm like
what should I do for my next YouTube
video and it takes me way too long to it
it sure no I get that same so like I'm
always working and I feel bad but so
that's why would say we should rent a
house for a year so we don't we had to
get new stuff new clothes because of our
stuff back in yeah
it was so much more expensive and so
this was last year this was the
beginning of this year beginning of this
year January oh dang grew it three
months
we're not don't worry it's not a math
podcast roll
yeah and so then we decided to I see I
didn't know what was gonna be when we
decided to do the three months I was
like okay well just get tried for three
months it didn't work like that it's
like okay come back I'm like wait wait I
I'm really like homesick and I miss my
dogs and family and so you've been out
here since no no I go back and visit I
was doing dance for a while gymnastics I
started doing dance girl where do you
stop waiting do you silly there's so
many things I want to talk about like
like the gymnastics social media acting
YouTube like yeah a lot of and then I
want to talk about like it's so many
different things so so you okay so then
you come out here the beginning of the
year and you work on this show that's it
is is this on the one that's on the brat
yeah so don't brat so I I was so for
this brat they they hire actors over
here and then they also just like like
give the roles to people like
influencers it's like an awesomeness TV
thing so it's all the family where the
people are bringing in influencers and
they're creating me shows people thought
that um
Brett like new hoot cuz like my friends
were like in brat like a lot of my
sister mediate friends like I know like
a lot of people that were doing Brett so
I think people thought that I just like
it's like hey Mia we want you to be on
this but I actually got it through like
actors access and I like audition for it
which of people for people that don't
know actors access is basically like the
Craigslist of acting in a way yeah and I
used to do this in New York yeah that
you basically go on this website you
submit yourself to all these auditions
yeah line ly with no representation
basically and then people can like keep
you out of whatever yes like my manager
was like submitting me on like big stuff
like movies and shows and like the
bigger things and I was just like I'm
out here so I want to do as much as I
can and I'm like okay I said I submit
him on my own stuff and I'm like I
submit it for myself on it and I was
like oh wow yeah so I submitted for
myself on that and I got it so I was I
wasn't in the first season that much but
I think I don't know if I'm are you
allowed to
this is this about are we gonna get an
exclusive piece of information right now
but season two of crown Lake I think I'm
gonna be in it more crazy
that's excited we're filming that also
I've ever heard of Bratz the network
yeah I thought it was like a Bratz dolls
Network so she's a Bratz doll yeah no I
thought that I thought that at first too
but yeah it's like but it's it steers to
like younger audience I know all the
kids love it it's like YouTube it's like
it's all on YouTube yeah and they have
like millions they get millions of views
and followers and so that they get like
more views than mostly like Disney
Channel really way more views and Disney
Channel I mean you know we love you
I'm gonna go submit myself through
actors access you know crown like season
3 excited for that and I'm really
excited for the trophies and I actually
just got like a short film like today
that's look at your before this yeah
thanks amazing ok let's talk about you
driving how's that going oh the biggest
audition of all time is can you drive a
car yeah mm-hmm I want us you guys
everything you got your license yeah I
got my license like a month ago or
something
yeah weeks ago like oh yeah like two
weeks ago yeah I watched the video of
you guys yeah you are so sweet because
it is the most terrifying thing in the
world to be put behind the wheel of a
giant like metal machine for the first
time I was excited to make the video my
dad's like man do you really want to be
filming yourself I yeah yeah I can't
believe your dad so you're filming
yourself driving by yourself for the
first time and your dad's in the car
next to you this is insane because not
only is driving by yourself for the
first time incredibly intimidating but
you have a camera yeah no I told him I'm
like I'm not gonna look at it I didn't
look at it once maybe watch the video I
didn't look like
I think I even said I hope this is
recording or else I'd be really worried
so I'm just talking to myself
and all the way back it was so much more
boring because I wasn't talking to
anyone I was just like you're forget the
road and I'm like so so have you driven
out here in Los Angeles no I well
actually I did when I had my permit just
with like first Gary I don't think I was
supposed to but I did it was really
quick it was just like around like the
corner but um I I don't know if I should
say this but okay I'm pretty good I I'm
a good driver at least in Maryland I
never liked our cars we have like a BMW
and that's the car I Drive in like a
truck like there are they're all like
electric cars like you just like push
you know and they're all the work for me
literally there's like the cameras like
you can see everywhere around you it's
so easy yeah and then so what decided
what I should say now what happen your
brain I didn't tell my mom this or my
brother's us or anyone this I told only
my dad okay dad I'm gonna tell you
something and you're not gonna tell
anyone I'm sorry I didn't tell you mom
but I didn't want you to freak out yeah
she's out the room okay I promise like
I'm a good driver
[ __ ] that's what a bad driver said I
have a good job I thought I made a
mistake so I by myself for the first
time yeah with one of my friends if
gymnastics I haven't seen her in like a
long time okay I was visiting home and
so I went there it was perfectly fine it
was like a lot of people it's on a
weekend okay I was like oh my gosh
there's a lot of people but it was fine
there everyone's everything was fine but
going out of them all it's like super a
mall parking lot is the scariest place
to drive is because everyone abandons
every rule in a parking lot I still to
this day I'm 33 years old have no idea
what the rules of the parking lot are so
I was about to turn out of this day it
was a left turn and it was like it
didn't say do not turn left so I'm like
okay you can turn left yeah I assume
everything's go if it I'm like should I
just like make a bunch of Rights until I
should go there
like I'm like you know what it's fine
let me just so I was like
second-guessing myself like should I go
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's mine
yeah and so I was about to turn this guy
came up and like went it's like looks
like he was about to stop but then he
just like kept going I'm like dude and
then I'm like he said I was like looking
at oh my gosh like yeah what I gave him
like the dude he had that Sears Portrait
Studio I was like geez and then after he
went I'm like okay so I was looking I'm
like jeez I'm about to go no I can't go
that guy just went okay now I could go
but then put the other side there's the
carly-girl room I was there when he went
he'd flip we didn't make any contact
okay he got his brakes I slander my
brake didn't I could see him he went I
did that I saw sorry I I was like
following him for a while because like I
had to like get out so it was really
awkward I'm like should I just like pull
over and just like wait for him to like
it doesn't even look like I can drive I
don't look 16 I feel like did this girl
like take the car and this child stole
their parents car and I want to take a
picture my license plate and be like
this person oh my gosh my heart was
beating I was like it's okay it's okay
and then I started second-guessing
everything I'm like I'm like wait so can
I go on this road is this it looked like
a one-way - we drive on the right side
of the street or the left side how does
it happen I'm serious yeah I was like
out of a turn I was like do I go in this
side I'm like no man I just focus
it's terrifying so yeah I told my dad
about that he was like ya know it was
like it's okay just next time if you're
saying guessing your felt if you're
second-guessing yourself just take all
the rights and like you like that was my
first time even driving in like the mall
like where no one direct me and I was by
myself
usually my dad's like okay go here go
here nope stop that bit okay go yeah
when you have someone that's giving you
exact I mean I still feel like I need my
dad in the passenger seat tell me how
the drive because I feel like out here
he would be absolutely disappointed with
the way that I drove even to this office
morning but my heart was beating I was
like I did not just do that and there
was another vibe and there was another
incident that I can't talk about on here
okay like no one knows it's fine nothing
had nothing bad I love that you preface
everything with it's fine everything's
fine everything's fine it's like another
things I was like that did not just
happen
guess what there's gonna be so many more
I promise
like if I like hit someone's car and
like made damage to it like I we would
pay for it like it's not like I like oh
you're never hit and run
you're being very sweet that you even
like think this happens to everyone in
Los Angeles constantly it's all your
good if I hit someone's car and made a
dent like I would have been like oh
shoot I'll put like a note and like do
that nothing happens
nothing everything was fine it's just
nothing else happened and I will never
tell it okay we're gonna take on this
note of you we're all finding out that
you're the best driver that's ever
existed we're in she's great we'll be
right back with more not too deep right
after this this episode of not to do is
sponsored by Buffy Buffy makes bedding
that is earth friendly and cruelty-free
the products are made using only
sustainable and recycled materials which
makes them as soft on the planet as they
are on your bed Buffy's latest product
the breeze is a comforter made entirely
from 100% eucalyptus fiber to regulate
temperature and keep you cool and
comfortable all night long it regulates
temperature which means no more night
sweats and guess what I suffer from
night sweats
you heard me and this is a the most
amazing product I cannot say enough good
things about it if you suffer from what
I call the you know dark time terrors
the night time anxiety the night sweats
as we will buffy's come
the breeze is absolutely incredible it's
made of eucalyptus fabric inside and out
it's softer than cotton a naturally
soothes skin and is also hypoallergenic
hypoallergenic
in fact it's high thread-count shuts out
dust mold and mites for a healthier
sleeping environment buffy also offers a
free trial try a comforter in your own
bed for free and if you don't love it
return it at no cost that's bonkers if
you don't love it return it at no cost
like I said I'm obsessed I have both
puffy comforters but the breeze who does
wonders on my night sweats on my night
moisture but why not choose 100%
plant-based bedding that's better for
you and the earth and you get $20 off
your Buffy comforter by visiting Buffy
dat CO and entering the code NTD again
that's Buffy dot C o code and TD for $20
off your Buffy comforter all right Mia
before we get into these Twitter
questions that I have for you I'm gonna
ask you the two questions asked every
single guest okay that is on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti at
Oh alive or dead
I don't know I might be going too deep
into this uh-oh I feel like this is it a
bad enough punishment I would want to
throw cold spaghetti at like Hitler's
just cold spaghetti he deserves like
boiling a hot spaghetti
you are wise beyond your years
no it's been a yeah that's a very
popular answer no no you're a majority
there yeah okay and the the second
question is to tell us and part of my
language your worst pants shooting story
or close or close call but you can only
tell us in three words or small phrases
so for example mine is college jogging
front lawn
No yeah I'm major amazing my work it's
like hmm should I say this one this one
this one no it's gonna be fun I love
that you have multiple story okay let's
see the first one that comes to mind
FaceTime what grandmas abort mission
[Laughter]
sorry for your grandma's house yeah my
dad's like my grandparents were like I
was waddling to the bed and they're like
did you just I'm like I don't need to
talk about this about talking and let me
handle my situation right now okay let's
get into these Twitter questions that we
have for you
first question how's Bella and the rest
of your dogs doing so how many dogs you
have in total okay okay this is my ride
your hands like this is the best topic
that we haven't gotten into my dogs they
are my best friend I don't care what
people like oh that's weird like I'm
very introverted like an extroverted
introvert yeah yeah like I people for it
whatever others my dogs or like people
friends a hundred percent I understand
exactly what you're saying yeah and like
I feel guilty like sometimes when it's
weird like I don't like going to friends
houses because I'm like no with my dogs
like they can't come like so I've had
all boxers like look you've all bought
yeah okay oh okay I'm very excited sorry
we just opened up just for my dogs
oh my team are on it but we've all
boxers I've had seven boxers so that's
insane I like crazy about my dogs I love
them there they are literally my
everything my favorite number is my dogs
my dog's my dogs my passwords are like
research it's like a secret it's all
good
like everything's my dog's like my lucky
number is my dogs like OCD too it's like
I have to I just like do things so many
times you're sure that things and like
it's like how many dogs I have I have to
do it that many times
I'm really so why limit three dogs
mm-hmm and then started before and I
just recently got a new dog so like I
keep doing six things I'm like no it's
seven seven wait I've had seven like I
still count the ones that passed away
because like I loved them all the same
like I like people that have not that I
don't like on white people that have
favorite dogs like my brothers have
favorite dogs but I'm like how like any
people ask me so much your favorite dog
I'm like oh I couldn't possibly yeah
like like I do not all of them they will
know if I answer them my parents keep
trying to get it out of me like they're
not gonna know I'm like stop saying okay
so how many do you currently have I
really have three three and what are
their names the ones I have now
Ozzy Bella and Jax Ozzy Bella and Jax
okay huh and they're all boxes they're
all boxers and the ones that passed away
is Bubba snoopin Oh Joe okay then we had
a really that two of them passed away
really early which was really
unfortunate um but they passed through
at like five so uh well boxers don't
live that long right words cuz they're
the best yeah I love all dogs like also
boxers to me are hilarious because they
look like a little deer trying to walk
for the first time their legs are always
so broken and awkward my one my one he's
a like a little tween he's like two
years old now he's he's more puppy than
the puppy we just got he goes into
everything he was like he got a light
bulb and he's like chewing it and like
that the puppy is like riding in her
crate like nervous like because he knows
what's that guy doing it all is like
it's like oh he gets into such bad stuff
but anyway well so question house Bella
is the great I miss her so much she's so
big I'm I'm doing a video like when I
first got her I did like a video in the
mirror I'm like holding her as
baby and I was doing it once a month I'm
like now it's like she's huge okay Bella
let's breathe three two I'm filming the
video and so I'm excited to post up
video I'm gonna post it when she's full
full grown she's got full full grown but
she's really really big now but she's
great
are you gonna get another one so we got
Bella because we wanted her to be with
us in California yeah because our other
dogs like it would be rude to like cuz
we live Thank You mr. mumbles what they
can they can it's just we live in the
suburbs and they live on like four acres
and a fenced and they can just go
wherever they want they can play here oh
they're gonna have a yard oasis yeah so
we thought we were just gonna be there
for the three months so we're like we
raised he weighs the puppy here yeah
this is our first time ever getting a
girl dog ever had six males but like we
had problems with fighting and then our
one dog we had two rehome it was really
unfortunate and I still really miss him
but they went to like our family friends
so oh that's good yeah
so then you were gonna raise her out
here yeah eraser out here and like bring
her back and then like every time we
came here we were gonna bring her back
with us so she fell in love with our
other dog and they're best friends they
do everything together they cuddle
together they eat and drink together and
they are literally they share bones
together like dogs like like dog they're
very little like aggressive like yeah
you have my boat like give it back
alright the teen dog that I say is more
like a puppy yeah he's in love with her
he's like you know what any other dog if
they tried to take his food he'd be like
get away her he's like he like Toby
gives like the high role like take it do
whatever he lets her crawl all over him
and like he lets her annoy the crap out
of him and he will do anything for she
stayed a very sweet and he can't hang
out with the other dogs so there's like
we have to like do some separating cuz
like there was a bunch of like crazy
like fighting stuff that's what happened
so that's why we had to get a girl so
it's just Jackson Bella hang out
together then Ozzy he's a lone wolf so
we wanted to bring out of
we're gonna try to bring Ozzy here he's
by himself and I just like moved out
into the pool house I'm really excited
about that skit that Ozzy out here but
then my mom and I were talking about
should we get like we're thinking like
are you gonna get another one my mom
wants to you guys are out of control for
once I'm the person like I used to be
like mom can we get another dog and
they'd be like no my parents used to my
parents are in love with our dogs now
like they like sleep on their bed they
caught it with them for the first four
dogs they'd be like no furniture no
that's no that they would sew strips
like out of this kitchen like they were
so so these dogs it's like any favor
we're on they're all in a bed I'm like
they they changed so much and they're
like oh those kids are getting older and
they're like our babies now I'm like but
like the rules have changed dramatically
like we can expect six to seven new dogs
in your future like if yeah okay ready
we got more Twitter questions for you
here's next question who I could talk
about my dogs all day I feel like I
unlock a Pandora's box
it's almost know who do you look up to
you do I look up my eye well I don't
okay so that's the thing I don't really
have a person like okay here's out of my
family I'm gonna revise this question
who do you watch online who do you
follow on the internet like who's the
goods like who's the person that you go
to it let you check in on or people
multiple yeah so I check it out who do I
want to or who do you watch like when
you go online do I watch I'll answer
that like I watch on to you do I like
thanks I'm good need to okay so I I like
I like david dobrik he's really funny
and I listened to your podcast with zane
and heath oh yeah yeah and I'm
definitely gonna start listening to your
podcast because I listen to so many but
like my mind is like crazy like if I if
you I don't even listen to my podcast
don't even worry about it
in a room with like just like by myself
like eating or like anything like my
mind will just go off and like think
about but your end of things and like so
I'm always listening to like a podcast
like I don't listen to music I'm always
trying to find new podcasts so I listen
to like a bunch of different podcasts
yeah feel free there's a plenty of
episodes I don't remember any of them I
listen to and watch so many yeah I so
you watch David Oh David Oh Beck I love
his I like his podcasts oh it yeah yeah
I just started watching um Jeff and
Todd's okay there's as well
I think Zen and Heath are starting a
podcast so that whole vlog squad they're
all really funny
that's very yeah and I also I know
people like I really actually do like
Logan Paul's podcasts okay like a people
might be like oh my god watch Logan Paul
but like his podcast I I like them
they're pretty good um so I listened to
that podcast
jenna Marbles podcast love her and she's
so down-to-earth and like it's like
different kids sometimes it's like
sometimes I don't like about the stuff
they're talking about like I get like
annoyed like like sure they're talking
about like more like crazy stuff and I'm
like huh like jenna Marbles podcasts are
always there like child-friendly and
like down there or there's like that's a
podcast I can put on in the car like my
family I can listen to way that your mic
can listen to with you that you won't be
embarrassed yeah it's like sometimes I'm
listening to the views podcast and I'm
like and they start talking about
writing stuff I'm like I think that's
enough podcasts like sometimes like
their stuff is a little because I'm not
like most 16 year olds I've been
homeschooled my whole life so I'm very
like it I don't like talk about all this
your mom seemed like really good friends
so same thing that if I played like
anything in the car with my mom and then
all of a sudden it started getting like
scandalous I'd be like I don't want to
listen to this with my mom right now
I don't even want to listen to it by
myself
that's enough for me okay here's another
question someone says this is stupid but
I think it's really telling of someone's
personality when you put your socks and
shoes on do you do it
sock shoe sock shoe or sock sock shoe
shoe I do sock sock shoe shoe
oh okay what do you do I'm now trying to
think what do I do
I think I do super flip-flops do I wear
shoes I mean I hardly wear socks so
maybe that's I just do shoe shoe and
hope for the best
haha yes sometimes I'm too lazy I'm like
it'll be fun and then later I'm like I
should put on socks my theater I then
thank God no one's around me has to
smell my feet okay what song has defined
your summer hmm I don't listen to a lot
of music honestly really yeah I listen
to podcasts Oh like when people like Oh
put on music like when they do podcasts
like I don't know songs like what's your
go-to let's say hypothetically let's
take you back to gymnastic years you're
getting pumped up for a meet you're
getting ready to go
what's your jam that you listen to that
ribs you are like I like hollaback are
like oh like Gwen Stefani oh yeah I love
that I also like Fergalicious oh yeah
yeah it gets you amped yeah it does yeah
I really like hollaback girl oh that's
good I mean that's a classic it gets me
like pumped up like let's go I have
dyslexia so like I get like I'm really
like I'm I suck at spelling I cannot
spell the good thing is we have
autocorrect on our phone yes thing but
that's good but like when I'm like
writing like there's some songs like
holla back girl be like now I know how
to spell banana for friends I could
never spell friends like I I would
always like switch yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then the song Fri Andy is we're just
friends like there needs to be like a
song
all the words again can't spell I feel
like this is a genre that you can start
entering into and you create if you want
to get into the music industry just make
music for spelling words that I'm just
putting it out there that this might be
a future
I've always okay so I love make doing
like music videos like with the videos
and like a bunch of my friends are like
getting in like to the singing stuff and
like they do your music videos I'm like
I want to do that but I can't sing oh so
I'm like maybe if I make it education
educational it's not about the voice
that's your hook feel like there you go
Mia this has been super fun yes what is
what's what's on the horizon what's in
the future for you right now um
hopefully more Act
I'm definitely got to start doing social
media more I'm gonna start posting on
schedule there you go as I you can do it
I believe and then we got a crown Lake
on Lake very excited about trophies I'm
very excited about wears trophies
trophies that's happening I'm not good
at the names of locations red California
LA but I mean like what what platform is
it on or example eventually I get to
like Netflix Hulu and so this is all in
the works right now that yeah I'm
filming the pilot this year and the next
year we're filming the first season oh
that's so cool yeah also before you go
every guest that is on the podcast gets
a personalized fortune cookie so this is
for you personalized it's personalized
there's a message inside that is
specifically and only for you how did
you get it in there it's our secret
Melissa does a really great job and some
already mm-hmm very satisfying oddly
satisfying yeah if you can fully break
it open Wow Wow
that did sound like someone cracking
their knuckles okay let's read this oh
can we get a ride to Taco Bell after
this because
now you can drive and I trust your
driving I actually don't I'm gonna go
give me a where can people find you
online you can find me on instagram mia
underscore Genoa oh I want to talk about
this I forgot I'm shadow band right now
what's that mean it's like people can't
find my account why it's I don't know
we're gonna on Instagram yeah like if
you search my name it doesn't come up
what like you have to like scroll Scroll
scroll and find it but it's Mia
am i i underscore di n ot oh it's good
there's my fan pages and like back up
extra accounts come up first and then
you have to like scroll and find mine so
we're gonna get that fixed hopefully by
the time this episode comes out yes
relinquish so that's my Instagram
YouTube
Mia Donato I'm gonna start posting on a
schedule every Saturday I'm not sure
what time yet yeah yeah and tick tock
and tick tock Mia - no no underscore and
I'm gonna try to get the usernames just
- Mia - no - but I think I believe in
you this was so fun thank you so much
thank you always want to be on podcast I
love pot I hear ya and don't forget to
subscribe to views the subscribe well
see you guys next time goodbye
- deep toe deep deep deep not too deep
is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
camera operator Katrina Henning edited
by Shireen Lonnie Eunice post production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]